this week
the team at treyarch is dropping a
mid-season update for call of duty black
ops cold wars season two
featuring new content for multiplayer
and zombies as well as a few global
changes that serves up a little
something for everyone buckle up because
we're going to jump into season 2
reloaded
expect three multiplayer maps this week
including miami strike
a 6v6 experience that tightens the
design from the original
offers a new layout and a new daylight
setting
mansion the new hotness for 2v2 and 3v3
including gunfight
gunfight blueprints face-off and more
and then
after debuting exclusively an outbreak
for the first half of the season
the massive new golova map comes to
multi-team modes
along with the insane new 40 player
hardpoint mode
miami strike will receive its own 24 7
playlist
and prop hunt will return with two new
maps miami strike
and satellite on the weapons front
the r1 shadowhunter crossbow is
available now
next week the zrg 20-millimeter sniper
rifle
will go live for everyone to unlock and
level up we should also know
that we're rolling out a new weapon
tuning pass this week
for more on that as well as what's in
store for upcoming features like on
fight tournaments
make sure to tune in to our blog at
treyarch.com
the start of season 2 introduced players
to outbreak
and the reaction has been amazing in
fact since its introduction more people
have played black ops cold war zombies
than ever before
including at launch we're happy to share
that this week outbreak is getting even
bigger
zombies gets its newest localeon
outbreak with sanatorium night
a massive new region to explore after
dark making everything undead
that much creepier it's an absolutely
huge new
area so make sure to partner up with
some talented teammates because
you're gonna need the help additionally
outbreak will feature the new
secure objective serve up crucial new
intel to discover
and feature the new dirt bike vehicle
also zombies players will now be able to
apply any blueprint they own to their
weapon
for a full list of everything that's
going into zombies as well as how the
dark ether story will continue an
outbreak through the next season
stay tuned to treyarch.com's blog
fans can also expect additions to dead
ops arcade
since launch dead ops has received a
great response from players
especially with the recent launch of its
first person mode this week
the team will feature a response to
player feedback providing player xp and
battle pass progression
additionally players will see a brand
new silverback slideways bonus map added
to the mix
for zombies fans on playstation get
ready for the new containment mode set
on the game's gunfight maps
take on a new blueprint challenge and
look for new item drops including level
2 and level 3 armor
plus new chalice drops that will pack a
punch your weapon for the first time in
onslaught
last but not least gunsmith customs
comes to black ops cold war allowing
players to mix and match attachments
from blueprints
of the same weapon type in create a
class across
all modes in war zone wolf joins the
roster of nato operators
as an elite delta force sniper next week
rivas will join the fight as our fourth
new operator in season two
and just like in multiplayer and zombies
the new zrg 20 millimeter sniper rifle
will be available to use in war zone
loadouts
once unlocked we hope that you enjoyed
all the double xp
double weapon xp and double battle pass
xp over the weekend
and that you're properly warmed up and
ready to go for the mid-season launch
check out the full road map on treyarch
social channels we'll see you
online